Oh
no one likes being stuck in traffic it's
noisy and stressful and more often than
not it causes you to arrive late what if
we could avoid traffic entirely sounds
pretty nice but what if we could not
only avoid traffic but get where we're
going in a matter of minutes rather than
hours and at a price far less expensive
than that of an airline ticket back in
2013 Tesla and SpaceX founder Elon Musk
first announced his goal to make that
vision a reality with an ambitious
project called the Hyperloop since then
musk has made the idea open-source
allowing and encouraging teams around
the world to make Hyperloop a reality
the project's ultimate goal is to
revolutionize transportation as we know
it by shuttling people and cargo between
destinations at speeds exceeding those
of commercial airliners all at the price
of a bus ticket musk wants the Hyperloop
to transport its first cargo by 2020 and
its first human passengers by 2021
having a functional Hyperloop by 2020 is
an exciting idea to be sure but is it
actually feasible to answer that
question let's start by examining the
history of tube travel the idea of
moving people and goods by pneumatic
tube has actually been around for quite
some time it was first proposed way back
in 1799 when British mechanical engineer
and inventor George Medhurst took out a
patent to transport goods by airtight
metal tube thirteen years later he wrote
a book on the subject though he never
pursued the idea himself throughout the
1800s there were several attempts at
implementing what commonly became known
as atmospheric railways which included
anything that used differential air
pressure to provide power for propulsion
one of the very earliest incarnations of
an air pressure power transport operated
for just two months in 1864 in South
London it was called the Crystal Palace
pneumatic railway which was a very grand
name for what amounted to a single train
coach propelled by a large fan down 550
meters of track the Crystal Palace is
thought to have been a prototype for a
proper pneumatic railway that would have
stretched from Waterloo to Whitehall a
project that was later cancelled
fast-forward to the 1910s and we get the
first concepts of vacuum trains from
American rocket pioneer Robert Goddard
it's these reduced pressure or vacuum
propelled transportation apparatus that
seemed to have the most in common with
the modern Hyperloop throughout the 200
or so year history of tube
transportation we've seen a series of
failed prototypes and novelty patents
but no real successes with that in mind
will the Hyperloop be any diff
let's look at some numbers musk
envisions cutting the travel time
between Los Angeles and San Francisco to
a mere 35 minutes he's proposed building
a high-speed transportation system that
would allow humans to travel at over
1,200 kilometers per hour or just shy of
the speed of sound
that's 610 kilometers or 380 miles in
just over half an hour that would indeed
revolutionize transportation if such a
system could be built so could it on the
surface the idea seems simple a long
tube very little friction and pods that
carry people and cargo in reality there
are a number of critical factors that
need to be addressed first is the issue
of temperature variations affecting the
length of the tube for example on a hot
day the middle of the tube would expand
causing its length to vary significantly
over the 610 kilometre distance modern
bridges often use what are called
expansion joints to account for shifting
temperatures the only problem with using
such expansion joints on an air tight
tube is that well it wouldn't be air
tight anymore the brains behind the
various Hyperloop projects plan to
counter the problem of temperature
variation another way the current
suggested solution is adding what
basically equate to giant expansion
joints at either end of the tube by
giant I mean these things will have to
be huge and allow over 300 meters of
movement between them to compensate for
the maximum amount of thermal expansion
they'd be very similar in design to the
extendable walkways used to board
aircraft some people speculate that
allowing for such a huge range of
variation simply isn't feasible and any
significant change in length could have
disastrous effect on the tube system
another problem is the current state of
transport pods in January of 2017 30
teams were selected from over a hundred
applicants to compete in the final round
of a SpaceX sponsored Hyperloop pod
design competition these finalists all
built prototype pods and competed for a
chance to make a test run through a 1.6
kilometre segment of Hyperloop test
track during this final stage of the
competition each pod was put through a
series of mind tests and only if they
passed those tests would they be able to
advance to the main event a test run in
the hyper tube of the 27 teams that
competed only three made it through to
the trial run of the three finalists
only one pod made it all the way through
the tube successfully the main problem
is that the whole setup is an assortment
of prototypes from the tube to the
propulsion methods to the pods
themselves the pods are significantly
smaller than they'd have to be in
Marshall format the tube itself had dust
problems and the propulsion method was a
small electric vehicle that pushed the
test pods a quarter of the way down the
track which would not be the case in a
full-scale Hyperloop of course at this
early stage there's not really much you
can do but use prototypes every
mechanical failure and design flaw is an
opportunity for improvement and that was
the whole purpose of the competition all
current challenges aside what effect
would have finished Hyperloop have on
modern transportation if Elon Musk's
vision becomes a reality the changes
would be dramatic first traffic could
become a thing of the past if Hyperloop
tickets are as inexpensive as they're
projected to be many people would gladly
pay to completely bypass their busy
commute with fewer people on the roads
that means less potential for accidents
and fewer fatalities not only would
there be fewer people in cars but also a
drastically reduced number of semi
trucks large transport trucks were the
cause of almost 4,000 deaths in 2015
with 69 percent of those deaths being
occupants of smaller cars if these cargo
trucks were replaced by cargo pods in
the Hyperloop we'd see a significant
reduction of fatal crashes traffic
slowdowns and presumably get the added
benefit of faster transfer of goods from
one place to another if we had the
Hyperloop another important factor to
consider is the economic impact not only
on companies but also on individuals
driving from London to Manchester takes
about four hours or two hours by train a
Hyperloop ride between the two cities
would take just 20 minutes that's great
for commuters but the biggest benefit to
the individual is the ability to live in
a less expensive area save money and
still be able to work in London's
booming economy property prices in
Manchester are about 1/10 of what you
can expect to see in London which makes
for huge savings for businesses the
Hyperloop would open up a massive new
population of workers able to commute
into the city during the day and back
home in the evening a trip that would be
time and cost prohibitive without this
new mode of transportation the Hyperloop
would also allow for a sort of
cross-pollination between cultural hubs
a ride from Stockholm to Helsinki would
take 28 minutes connecting the two
economies and those of the smaller
cities in the surrounding areas which
would redefine regions and cultural hubs
as we understand them no longer would it
be unreasonable to live 200 kilometers
from work or 300 or even 500 the
Hyperloop would open up many new
possibilities for the workforce of the
near future would it become the most
popular method of transportation May
some people are concerned that the
massive length and fragile nature of the
tube would be a tempting target for
terrorist attacks and perhaps that
thought would steer some people away
from using the Hyperloop at first
however if it does all its projected to
do if it allows people to travel across
huge distances in a short amount of time
if it's cheaper than a plane ticket and
if it's truly safe to use then yes the
Hyperloop could very well become the
transportation method of the future yes
there are many obstacles to overcome
before it becomes a reality but to all
those who say it's impossible
remember that progress is made by
pushing the envelope and doing things
that others consider crazy consider this
quote from the quarterly review in 1825
what can be more palpably absurd than
the prospect held out of locomotives
traveling twice as fast to stagecoaches
Hyperloop one is currently building the
first full-scale and full-speed
prototype called dev loop in the deserts
of Nevada and hope to hit their 1,200
kilometer per hour speed goal by the end
of 2017 the Hyperloop is still a very
young technology and despite as many
challenges and barriers to success it
will most definitely be exciting to
watch it grow into what will hopefully
become a revolutionary shift in
transportation if you'd like to learn
more about the Hyperloop and tube
transport check out the links in the
description be sure to subscribe if you
haven't already and follow second
thought on your favorite social media
thanks for watching and I'll see you in
the next video